Okay, in this problem, which if the following criteria are provided by the Standard Penetration
Test or SPT?
On-drained shear strength directly measured, relative density of cohesionless soils indirectly
measured, the soils optimum water content directly measured, the soils maximum dry density
directly measured.
So again, we have another conceptual problem here.
And the following steps are how we can try to solve for the right answer, even if we don't
know much about geotech.
So obviously the question has asked us about the SPT.
The first thing we could do in our reference manual is search SPT.
Now that's going to lead to a few different things first.
By the time you get to the fifth occurrence in chapter 3, this should take you to section
3.8.1.3 titled SPT correlations.
Now previous occurrences of the SPT bring us to things that are using the SPT value versus
another factor or value.
It's also worth noting that the word correlation in the title implies that the results are
in-exact, which would lead me to look for answers with the term indirect in it.
So this already possibly removes two of our answers from up top.
If we were running out of time, we could try to make an educated guess from here.
The next thing we could look at is looking at the SPT table on page 131 of the reference
manual in section 3.8.1.3.
We can see that one of the terms in the field includes the term relative density in the
table about SANS.
Relative density.
And it notes that for SANS this is reliable.
And for SILTS and CLASES that it can be unreliable.
The one thing you would need to know in this case is that SANS are a cohesionless soil
while SILTS and CLASES are not.
That is to say they have cohesion.
So this is the one piece of information you would need to know to note the difference between
a SAND and a SILTS or CLASES as it pertains to this problem.
And finally based on points 3 and 4, I would say there's enough information here to strongly
suggest that our answer is B.
So this is one way in which you can try to solve for the answer in a conceptual problem
even if you're not very strong in the particular subject matter, in this case, GOTEC.
We were able to look at the word correlation for a HINTS which we found after searching
for the exact term that the question was asking about, or in this case the type of test,
and between the word correlation, implying an inexact form of measurement, the relative
density as one of the parts of the table and understanding that CLASES are reliably
SANS are cohesionless and reliable measurements whereas SILTS and CLASES have cohesion
and are unreliable.
That narrows down the answer to the final one here.
And that's it.